what's going on everybody welcome to yet
another SQL plus Python tutorial video
and really my sequel plus Python
tutorial video where we left off I was
just showing you guys we could run this
query here select all and this is kind
of how we can communicate with our
database by a Python now my goal here is
really to finish up this little
miniseries here by connecting it to
Twitter and we want to pull you know the
time user name and their that users
tweet store that into the database
so moving along in that along those
lines we need to make a few
modifications to this code so I'm going
to leave this here because at the end of
the operation we might as well print it
out to see if it worked so I'm just
going to hit a couple of blank lines
here for us and now since we're not
hooked up to Twitter let's just kind of
make a fake connection here and just say
that the variable we find is username
because we do split up the tweets and
get the username anyway so in the tweet
so eventually we do have this so if you
have follow those Twitter tutorials you
can see how we'll connect it anyways but
we'll say the username is Python and
that user tweets man I'm so cool typical
Python anyway so the next thing that we
want to do is actually execute and
insert query but we want this query do
to allow for these variables right so we
want user name and tweet to be variable
and we only we don't want to like have
to change this query every single time
right so we're going to do C dot execute
and we're going to use string formatting
for it so we're going to see that
execute and what we're going to execute
here is an insert query since we insert
into and then your table name in our
case is table and then we're going to
specify the columns that we're inserting
into so that's going to be the time
column the username column and the tweet
column
then we're going to say values
that's what values do we want to put in
there and then within here where any % s
% s and % s now in SQLite it was
question mark question mark question
mark and here it's % s so once you've
done that add a comma and now we're
going to add one more little variable
here
and that's going to be the data so we're
an answer one time time so whatever it
since this will be running on the server
it's going to be based on server time
which probably GMT but or you can see
username and then tweet so time to time
use name n tweet it gets inserted then
one more thing we do need to do I'm not
sure why the indentation is doing that I
don't know if it's just this editor
that's normally whenever you do it with
an idle and you get this you're you know
you've screwed up you haven't finished
off your job but I think that all my we
got one two three four openings and
we've got one two three four closing so
we're set I don't know why I guess
that's just kind of like a glitch in
their editor so now we'll do
kondeh commit and this basically
finished this is the job so it's like
you can consider this like as if you
were writing into your text editor
something conduct commit saves that
right so this is there but if you exited
out or you lost power you would have let
you would lose it so commit commits back
and then we're all set and then we'll
just go ahead and and have it execute
all from table and I guess we'll find
out real quick if this is a valid query
I don't see anything I don't see the air
I just feel like it would be kind of
weird like why it's doing this to us
but anyway I'll hit save and run and see
what happens let's do
way and x6g so execute is misspelled so
c dot execute okay try again
time is not the font man we're just all
over the place they apparently m4 time
one more try
I feel like we're like still waiting to
see if we got like the error that I
think I have no okay so there is no
error there I guess it's just kind of an
issue with the little IDE here so as we
can see that we did get this to insert
into the database because there it is
for us python man I'm so cool awesome
awesome so that's how we can insert data
and now obviously the last thing to do
is just add in the the actual Twitter
stream and then maybe change the
variables to match that Twitter stream
they pretty much be a copy and paste job
and then save and run and go the only
thing I suggested in case I forget to do
it I don't know how many seconds we even
have left probably us still okay yeah we
still have you know over well ninety six
and a half seconds but that Twitter
stream especially if you pick you know a
pretty hefty word I mean you're going to
run through your entire 100 CPU
allowance like instantly they do have
like like this kind of like backup tar
pit that they call it and so everything
will just run really slow there but yeah
just keep that in mind I'll have to
think of like a really like or I guess
we could just use like any word and then
we'll just add like a timer to it so so
I can just show you for example and I'll
stop the script and it won't you know
kill the CPU anyway so that's what we
doing the next video is mention it with
Twitter and actually getting that to
save these tweets to our database again
I'm going to mention though you can't
store tweets for more than 24 hours
officially it's not like they're going
to just blow up but you can't do it so
that's my little warning to you guys
I'll warn you again on the next video
so I
so you'd want to be able to do you know
whatever analysis or whatever you want
to do within that 24-hour period and
delete those tweets or better thing you
can do is actually as the tweet comes in
and analyze the tweet and do it that way
that's the way I do it and no you don't
don't worry about any any troubles and
shenanigans so anyway so the next video
tying it to Twitter as always thanks for
watching thanks for the support stripper
tunes and until next time